5 54 here on your monday morning well
learning a whole lot more about las
vegas boulevard in front of resorts
world
by going to baggage claim at the airport
yes you're going to be able to check off
several junior buddy boxes
after this hanging out unobtrusively
next to carousel
6 in the terminal 1 baggage claim
is this very cool architectural model
of the entire resource world complex
we can talk more about the pool on the
south side of the tower or the employee
parking overlooking the d.i super
arterial
but for today las vegas boulevard in
front of resorts world now clark county
has indicated that starting the day of
the opening next thursday the 24th
running all the way to july 5th
southbound drivers on the strip will
have all lanes
open directly next to the project and at
least two lanes from sahara south of
spring mountain
also two lanes for northbounders except
for overnight from 2 am to 10 am
but the real point of today's story
projected locations for not one
but two pedestrian bridges
one over di the other further north
coming out from around the middle of the
building's east side
so go ahead check off your junior
traffic buddy
junior architect buddy and junior
resorts world buddy boxes
so we know where the bridges are going
to be but we don't have a
timeline for them but keep it right here
for all your resorts world updates
they're also available 24 7 on our
website you can find the online version
of this and all our stories at
8newsnow.com when you click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put on that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
you can email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com